Believe it or not, we've just finished our first order
of the Critical Rendering Path. Let's do a quick review.
>> Hold on. What about JavaScript?
>> Okay. Fair enough So, JavaScript can manipulate both the DOM and
the CSS object model. But otherwise, the Render process is the same.
>> Mm-hm. I see So, what kind of performance
optimization should I keep in mind when I'm using JavaScript?
>> That's a great question. And, we'll get into
a lot of details on how to optimize JavaScript
in one of the future lessons. But before
we get to that, let's do a quick review.
>> Try summarizing what we've learned so far
about the first path through the Critical Rendering Path.
You don't need to write an essay. Just list
the steps in order that they happen, and post
your answers to the forum, under the post called,
Steps to Render a Page. Or, if you don't
have access to the forms right now, find a
friend and explain the Critical Rendering Path to them.